In this segment, we make a
connection between the
correlation coefficient and
some fairly realistic real
world situations.
The bottom line will be that
the presence or absence of
correlations can make
a huge difference.
Suppose that you run an
investment company that
invests in real estate, and
you have 100 million of
capital that you
want to invest.
Now you have learned or believe
that it helps to
diversify, to not put all of
your eggs in the same basket.
And for that reason, you're
going to invest some of your
money into different states.
You will be investing in 10
different states, and in each
state, you will invest 10
million so that your total
investment is spread between
those 10 states.
For each state, you have a model
that tells you that the
return on your investment,
that is your profit--
It's, of course, random, but you
expect it to be 1 million
on the average, that is, in
terms of the expected value,
but there's also a fair amount
of randomness, and so the
standard deviation is 1.3.
Now, if you look at one state
in isolation, it would be a
pretty risky investment because
the standard deviation
is comparable to the mean.
It's not an unlikely event to
have a return that's one
standard deviation
below the mean.
And if that happens, your
return is going to be
negative, and you're
losing money.
But then you argue that
you're investing in
10 different states.
Yes, you might lose money in
some of them, but overall, you
would expect to have a pretty
high confidence that you will
end up having a positive
return.
Is this correct or not?
Let us do some calculations.
We will look at the variance
of your total return.
The variance of the sum of
random variables is given by
the formula that we
have developed.
It's the sum of the variances.
But then you also have a bunch
of covariance terms that have
to do with the relation of the
different random variables.
Now, you make the assumption
that the different states are
different markets--
one doesn't affect the other--
so that the Xi's are
uncorrelated.
In that case, in this variance
formula, the covariance terms
are all 0, and they disappear
and you're left with the sum
of 10 variance terms.
Now, each one of these variances
is equal to the
square of the standard
deviation.
And we have a variance
of 16.9.
You then take the square root to
find the standard deviation
and the square root of
this number is 4.1.
Now, your expected return is
equal to 10, which is 2 and
1/2 standard deviations.
You will only lose money if
the outcome is 2 and 1/2
standard deviations
below the mean.
And that's a fairly unlikely
outcome, and so in this
situation you feel very
confident that you will have a
positive profit.
Suppose, however, that your
assumption is wrong, and that
actually the different Xi's are
correlated with each other.
And suppose that the
correlation is
pretty high, 0.9.
Essentially, this means that the
real estate market in one
state is strongly related to the
behavior of the market in
another state.
And that could be, perhaps,
because the markets in
different states are affected by
some more global phenomenon
that operates on a
national level.
So in this case, the covariance
of Xi with Xj is
going to be the correlation
coefficient times the standard
deviation of Xi times the
standard deviation of Xj,
which is 0.9 times
1.3 times 1.3.
And so the co-variance
turns out to be 1.52.
And in that case, the variance
of the sum, using this formula
here, is going to be equal to 10
times the variance that you
have in each state, which is 1.3
squared, plus you have a
bunch of terms here.
How many terms?
There's 90 of them, and
each one of these
terms is equal to 1.52.
And the variance turns
out to be 154.
Now you take the square root
of that, and you find a
standard deviation of 12.4.
Now, your expected profit
is 10, but the standard
deviation is 12.4.
And if you happen to be one
standard deviation below the
expectation, which is something
that has a sizable
probability of occurring,
then your profit
is going to be negative.
So in the uncorrelated case,
you're pretty certain that you
will have a positive profit,
but if the correlations
actually turn out to be
significant, then you're
facing a very risky situation.
To some extent, this is similar
to what happened
during the great financial
crisis.
That is, many investment
companies thought that they
were secure by diversifying and
by investing in different
housing markets in different
states, but then when the
economy moved as a whole, it
turned out that there were
high correlations between the
different states, and so the
unthinkable, that is large
losses, actually did occur.